LUCAS CUSUMANO: Thank you.
Open your mouth and say, aah.
GALEN MURPHY-HOFFMAN: Aah.
LUCAS CUSUMANO: Excellent.
Any pain?
NARRATOR: Scenes like
this take place every day
in doctor's offices.
And at Einstein
Medical Center, that's
exactly what this is, a scene.
The doctor is a medical student.
And a patient, an actor.
LUCAS CUSUMANO: Any
pain right there?
OK.
NARRATOR: At facilities
around the country,
medical schools employ
standardized patients, or SPs,
who are often
professional actors,
to give students an education
into the real world.
GALEN MURPHY-HOFFMAN: We
are creating characters
with the information that the
medical school will give us.
In order for it to be
effective, we as actors
have to truly believe that
we're in the pain that we're in,
and we need the
help that we need.
MARLENA DATER: You
have certain lines
that when they ask you
this, you should say this,
to keep it standardized
while the students are
given equal opportunity.
And also it's videotaped.
The students get
to go back later,
and look, and watch, and see.
And also I'm grading the
students as well, not only
on their history taking and
their physical exam skills,
but most importantly, how they
made me feel as a patient.
NARRATOR: Testing scenarios
range from simple office visits
to comforting family members
that might have just lost
a loved one.
The cases are full
of details and clues
that the students must navigate
to find the right diagnosis
or response.
LUCAS CUSUMANO:
Perfect, excellent.
GALEN MURPHY-HOFFMAN:
And sometimes there
are red herrings.
Sometimes there is information
that you think is significant,
but in fact, it's in there to
send them down the wrong path
and to trap them.
LUCAS CUSUMANO: When someone
came for a shot then,
what were you doing at the time?
GALEN MURPHY-HOFFMAN: I
had just finished lunch.
LUCAS CUSUMANO: OK.
GALEN MURPHY-HOFFMAN: It came
on as I was [? in labs. ?]
LUCAS CUSUMANO: How
severe is this pain?
GALEN MURPHY-HOFFMAN: It's
probably a six or a seven.
LUCAS CUSUMANO: OK.
DR. FELISE MILAN: Using this
kind of modality for assessment
has really become the gold
standard, if you will,
in medical education.
And ultimately in
their fourth year,
the students have to pass a 12
encounter standardized patient
test to get a license
in this country.
LUCAS CUSUMANO: I would
say the first time I ever
worked with an SP, it
was a little daunting.
I didn't really even know
what to do, other than to say,
hi, my name is Luke.
GALEN MURPHY-HOFFMAN: And It
won't be my heart, will it?
LUCAS CUSUMANO: Oh, what's
going on with your heart?
Are you concerned
about this being--?
GALEN MURPHY-HOFFMAN:
Well, I-- just my father
had a heart attack
and died of it.
So I, was-- I guess,
just wanted to make sure
that-- I don't know if
anything in the stomach
is about the heart.
LUCAS CUSUMANO: I think
that's the reality of what
a health care system is now.
We have to make these very
empathetic interactions
happen very quickly,
and get the information
as quickly as possible,
while still trying
to maintain our
humanity and everything
that people expect as doctors.
NARRATOR: According to the 2016
Medscape Physician Compensation
Report, most patients
only have 13 to 15 minutes
with their doctor at
an average appointment.
Doctors have to learn to
be efficient in that time
but also develop
a bedside manner.
MONICA: Hi, Joanne.
My name's Monica [INAUDIBLE].
I'm a medical student.
I'm working with
your doctors today.
MARLENA DATER: My
favorite role to play,
and one I get cast in a
lot, is adolescent roles.
It's an acting process
for me, just trying
to be, like, disinterested.
Oh my god, I don't
really want to be here.
MONICA: Why do you think your
mom wanted you to come in?
MARLENA DATER: I
don't know, like,
I've been having
these headaches,
but, like, I don't think it's,
like, a big deal, but whatever.
If she does, she'll come in.
MONICA: Can you tell me some
more about the headaches?
MARLENA DATER: I don't know.
I don't know, it's,
like, a headache.
How do you explain that.
DR. FELISE MILAN:
We're really asking
them to use multiple
parts of their brain
at once, because
they're concentrating
on being another person and
truly being in that role.
At the same time,
they have to remember,
did the student ask
me if I had a fever?
Did the student ask me
what medicines I take?
And how did the
student ask me that?
To watch them do what they do,
and to see how fabulous they
are at it, is remarkable.
MARLENA DATER: Standardized
patient work, it's
like immediate
gratification and reward.
Because you are
affecting a student.
You're affecting future
doctors of the world.
And that sense, the world itself
because of all the patients.
And it's just such
a rippling effect.
I love this work, love it.
NARRATOR: Watch
this next episode
about a group of
grad students who
are developing a game changing
technology by converting a cell
phone camera into a microscope.